we've been using sign-in triangles quite
a while now we've been using in writing
the triangles like you were just doing
for bearings and for angles of
depression and so on and just very
recently we've been exploring actually
it's useful even when the triangles
aren't right angle if I gave you
something like this if I gave you
something like this triangle with no
right angles in sight we can use there I
need another color we can use what's it
called again let's go sign in it we can
use the sine rule we can say oh look I
have an angle opposite sign and I'm
interested in another angle opposite of
sine so in this case I could write what
would we write actually just have a look
at it you don't need to write it down
just to say it with me what's the thing
I'm looking for the angles so which one
am I going to use which four am I going
to use the one with sign first so I'd
say sine theta divided by 15 that's
opposite equals sine 25 on 10 and then
you go ahead from there okay so cool
it's useful however sigh this is we kind
of feature to it which is why the sign
oh isn't the only thing later on this
lesson we're going to learn is a cosine
rule I'll show you that shortly so I
always show you why does this weird
puzzling thing sine 30 sine 45 etc this
is just sort of instantly for our
calculators we don't know what these are
exactly so what should I reach for your
calculator and I just want you to help
me get like let's just get a couple of
decimal places for each of these because
some of them go on for read luck okay
now sine theta degrees does anyone go
there
interestingly it is exactly a huff
that's kind of weed but we're just leave
it for now sine 45 can I have another
decimal point so maybe more than two
actually like a seven point sine sixty
do you read me through this one last one
zero point right okay now I could have
done this for pennies Senate angles that
I like but these are kind of nice round
angles here's where it gets a bit creepy
okay again with your calculator this
time I would like it input not sign any
of these angles but sign a hundred and
fifty degrees sine 150 and what you'll
notice is for some reason it's exactly
0.5 just like sine 30 boys right okay
I'm gonna give you another one can you
do in your calculator sign of a hundred
and thirty-five instead if you do sign
hundred thirty-five what you'll notice
is it's 0.707
and all of the different places if you
have an amazing memory notice are the
same huh now before I tell you the next
one I wonder if you can look and guess
what might I try next I'm gonna try sign
a hundred and twenty degrees and
suspiciously you're going to find it's
0.866 anyone brave enough to try the
last one thank you well then they
practically hand up sign a hundred and
five you should find really
exactly the same 0.96 six whatever it's
the same as 75 degrees okay
now by now hopefully you can see a bit
of a pattern what's the UM what's the
relationship between the angles that
I've got here yeah each of these pairs
that I've got here I've got one more
color this one and this one
3450 now give you 180 45 plus 135 and so
on and so on
did you have a question correct right
now I'm not quite gonna go there but
that's what it is now just think for a
second they all add up to 180 these
pairs of angles do you remember we have
a name for when angles add up to 180
degrees there's something that's very
good so let's just put some arrows okay
sir this is kind of a peculiarities the
way I would guess I would say this is
that you could buy that you can try any
other combination in your life try cyant
twenty-nine degrees if you wanted some
weird number no idea what it is but I
can assure you that sine 29 will be the
same as sine 151 because they add up to
a hundred degrees now unfortunately it's
caused a bit of trouble for us let me
show you why if I said sine x equals
like I did this right that's speed up
sorry
sine theta equals and then after I did
all of my working you know I rearranged
the whole equation I punched into my
calculator and out popped out a half
okay what am I gonna do next like on the
calculator what am I gonna push I'm
gonna press shift sighs I want to kind
of undo this right and your calculator
and faithfully tell you as according to
the left hand side we just did the
calculator will faithfully tell you yeah
feed is 30 degrees but he's the thing
what you're telling your calculator to
do is hey there's some angle I don't
know what it is
when I do side of that angle apparently
the answer is a hawk can you tell me
what the angle is and it gives you a
solution however it's not the only
solution there's another angle in fact
there's an infinite number of angles
that if you do sine of that angle you'll
still get back that right so like 30
degrees could be the answer but 150
degrees could also be people now what we
call this is the ambiguous cases
ambiguous as to which one it is okay now
we don't wanna stress too much the
difference between each of these angles
is this one is acute right this one is
not acute it's obtuse it's bigger than a
right angle now you actually can work
out therefore when you go through this
whole process you need to do one of two
things look at your diagram if the
diagram is provided if they show you
some things like this and we're actually
going to do this one together if I say
here's the angle I'm after and this
angle is clearly bigger than 90 degrees
do you agree like it's very obviously
draw okay join us diagram with me I'm
gonna fashion up some numbers let's make
this
okay so suppose this is the triangle
that I give you just like in all the
other examples that we've seen I'm going
to notice oh look I've got say again 50
degrees I've got an angle and the side
it's opposite
I want this angle and I have the side
opposite down as well okay so I do my
normal thing on my diagram just like I
did up here I'm going to pan that and
I'm gonna pair that so what wine should
I write to help me work this out first
thing it's the sine rule so I'm gonna
write sine theta
what's it matched to fatty so it is
equal to and then I'm going to do the
other pair sine 15 degrees over 20 I
didn't take that 30 over to the other
side now just for the sake of it coming
up to get the decimals here this is
gonna your calculator is going to
calculate something for you can we get
what the number is
if start with a zero point give me four
okay so that's what sine theta H was
equal to but of course we don't what
side theta we want theta okay so you're
gonna go shift sign now watch what kind
of angle that provides to you what's the
size of the angle let's just get nearest
degree anyone 23 that's what the
calculator tells you but clearly that
copy 23 degrees that doesn't right look
at it it doesn't match up properly okay
it doesn't fit the diagram occasionally
if they don't give you a diagram they'll
actually say to you don't just find
theta
finally obtuse value of theta rather
than just what the calculator hands you
which is clearly not obtuse okay so you
can say but theta is of juice either
there's the question we flat out tell
you in words or the diagram will be very
very clear therefore remember 3150 4535
etc they add together to make 180 so I
need the angle that's on the outside
what do I add to this 157 right that's
the real angle and that looks a little
more healthy doesn't it like it's really
really why of course it is 157 fits the
bill so again a bit of a reminder right
and maybe I'll put this right next to
your diagram in assessments in examples
either read look for the word obtuse
if they want you to find that angle
they'll tell you or look at the diagram
inspect it closely and see whether the
angle that they are after is clearly not
less than 90 degrees that's a huge April
so they must want the big one okay now I
didn't decide it before because I hadn't
explained it but question six
I actually maybe I did a sign
question six in this most in Milazzo
exercise which I do fish now so they can
move on to the next thing
is all about these obtuse angles it's
all about the into savings I'm pretty
sure every question in question six
every part yeah it just says find the
obtuse angles theta so you're going to
get to hear your calculator don't tell
you that but then you have to say no
wait but these are meant to be something
else so find the supplement and you're
done okay